tout a commencé avec un jeune homme elle
m'a dit qu'il l'avait persuadée de voix
entre son âme
d'accord mais je te le dis tu es obligé
de jouer seul
choisissant un il t'a choisi tu devras
marché jusqu'à la croisée des chemins et
tu devras dire ton nom pourquoi les
jours il viendra il t'appellera par ton
nom
on veut vraiment vendre la maison
nous voulons la mettre sur le marché
aussi vite que possible on va vendre
votre maison
notre fille ollandini ça doit être élu
que j'ai vu ce matin pourtant elle est
ici dans votre maison
moi je connais même dis moi qui tu es ce
n'est pas toi que je veux
dis moi tout ce que tu sais sur elle
elle disait qu'un homme lui rendais
parfois visite
elle disait aussi qu'il entrait en elle
ils cherchent une maison à l'omaha
l'existence about
alors je crois qu'un à se sacrifier pour
empêcher ceux qui avaient pris
possession d'elle d'achever ce pourquoi
il l'avait choisie
elle a fait un pacte avec toi alors tu
as attendu de trouver une autre personne
dans laquelle tu insinues est la chose
qui s'était insinué en l utiliser son
corps comme un terrain